Where should you live in a zombie apocalypse?
As with most things, location is
everything, and not all communities
on The Walking Dead are created equal. Here
is a ranking of each one from worst to best.
Huge points get taken off for this community
because they don't allow themselves to settledown.
This faction decided early on that they
didn't want to bother with hanging onto the world
that was. Instead, they decide to cede control of
the planet to the zombies by living among them.
Rather than build walls to keep the walkers out,
they wear cured-flesh masks that allow them to
blend in with the dead, even strategically
herding them for their benefit at times.
Part of their philosophy is that humanity needs to
get back to its more animalistic roots. Therefore,
they operate on a societal basis of hierarchy,
with an Alpha leading their every
move and making all their decisions.
Although they successfully eliminate
walkers as a threat to their daily lives,
it just doesn't feel like a great way to live. The
worst part is that a Whisperer is always at the
mercy of their Alpha. If Alpha decides the herd
is moving one way, that's the way they're going.
If Alpha decides to start a war with well-armed
humans, they're going to war. In short, there's
not much difference between a Whisperer and a
regular zombie other than, technically, freedom.
"We are the walking dead."
This is a great example of something that
sounds terrific on paper being
absolutely awful in practice.
At the onset of the apocalypse, a handful of
police officers in Atlanta manage to maintain
their rank in society amongst a hospital skeleton
crew as the city falls into anarchy. Their leader,
Dawn Lerner, has the respect of her
fellow officers due to her rank,
which means increasingly less
with each passing, lawless day.
Eventually, supplies dwindle and Dawn implements
a system of taking survivors in for medical
treatment, only to force them to pay off
the debt they've incurred for being saved.
Unable to keep the tense community afloat,
Dawn resorts to more hostile measures,
basically enslaving anyone that the police
find. In a world where humanity is scarce and
decisions are being made on a life-or-death
level, having to defer to the judgment
and power of a former law enforcement
officer just sounds like a nightmare.
For Dawn and her citizens, life becomes
about serving a singular goal — keeping her
in power. That seems like a great deal
for Dawn, less so for everyone else.
Woodbury gets credit for being one of the
first safe havens built from the ground up
after the onset of the apocalypse.
Early on in the show's timeline,
The Governor leads a small group of people to
clear out, fortify and make the town somewhat
self-sustaining at a time when most
other people were wandering the woods.
Under The Governor's leadership, they even
manage to plant crops and get the power back
on so that some small slice of normal life
was restored to a little more than 70 people.
However, although comfortable, the
residents of Woodbury are completely
unaware of the day-to-day danger they
face — mostly from their insane leader.
"I'm sorry, it's just this
place… I can't stay here."
"Why?"
"The Governor. He is not what he seems to be."
The viewers know The Governor to be a heinous
individual capable of horrific crimes.
However, the average person who sees
tomatoes growing in their neighborhood
probably isn't looking too closely at where
the latest shipment of supplies came from.
This ignorance comes to a head during the
war with Rick Grimes' group in the prison.
The citizens of Woodbury think themselves
the good guys when they launch their attack,
but some of the survivors of the battle
are cut down by The Governor himself.
Not exactly a community where
you can depend on your leader.
Once you survive the apocalypse, the
question becomes what kind of day-to-day
life is acceptable for you to survive
in? For the members of The Scavengers,
the answer to that question has a pretty low bar.
While the people around them are clearing
out prisons, factories and small towns,
a woman calling herself Jadis
decides to claim a junkyard.
On paper, it sounds bad. However, if you're
looking to survive, it provides security as
well as resources like scrap metal and even
some food. Meanwhile, Jadis' policy of rarely
risking her people's lives or even revealing
their presence to the world means that they
avoid conflict while living in relative
comfort with plenty of essential supplies.
Eventually, though, the war in the area becomes
so large that Jadis and her people fall into the
hands of The Saviors. Until then, however,
Jadis has a resource-heavy community full of
loyal people who stayed out of sight and therefore
out of mind. They were even making groovy artwork
and adopting weird eccentricities like only
speaking in broken English. These are things
that people have the luxury to experiment
with once safety isn't really a concern.
Speaking of odd diction choices in the apocalypse,
The Kingdom takes the cake by forcing its
most loyal members to adopt a Renaissance
Fair style of English as they pledge
fealty to their founder and king, Ezekiel.
"What do you think of the Kingdom?
What do you think of the king?"
While having to perform a character as
family members die and society crumbles
all around you is challenging to say the least,
The Kingdom is one of the nicer places to live.
Early in the apocalypse, Ezekiel sees potential
in an abandoned school and fortifies it as a
place to build a community. Unfortunately,
it isn't around a lot of natural resources,
nor is it in the most defensible spot. However,
that doesn't stop him from putting in the work
and turning it into a self-sustaining
safe haven. Unfortunately, his hold on
The Kingdom is interrupted by The Saviors
coming in and demanding a piece of the pie.
It doesn't take long before the resources
and good nature of The Kingdom and its
citizens dwindle. While the community
gets credit for changing with the times,
the fact is that Ezekiel invests long term
in a place with a short expiration date.
The Prison may seem like a great place to live,
and Rick and his group of survivors do their
best to make it one for a long time. However,
the logistics of maintaining a
prison are a constant struggle.
For one, the place was designed to be maintained
by a large staff of guards, cooks, administrators,
and more. When in doubt, prison labor filled in
the gaps. When the survivors arrive, it's up to
a little more than a dozen people to manage a
massive facility. While blocking off a section
of the prison is easy enough, they are constantly
plagued by walkers getting past the gates.
Meanwhile, its curbside appeal makes
it a constant target for attacks,
which is ultimately how the prison falls. In a
desperate world, having something as shiny and
secure as a prison is too often an invitation
for outsiders to take what isn't theirs.
A place can be as safe as possible from walkers,
but as the show constantly reminds its audience,
human beings are the real threat in this world.
The community of Oceanside is
created after another settlement
falls to the ruthless tactics of the Savior Simon.
After suffering a defeat that sees every
male member of their society executed,
the women and children flee to
re-establish themselves elsewhere.
They become the first group on this
list to utilize their natural geography
by putting the ocean at their back to prevent
walkers coming at them from every side.
They decide that sharing what they
have with the world is no longer an
option because someone like Simon will
eventually strong arm their way into taking it.
As a result, they spend most of their
time doing the bare minimum to survive
while getting rid of anyone that might make
their presence known to the rest of the world.
Unfortunately, their main concern is staying
hidden, which prevents them from really building
the Oceanside community into something grand
until after Rick's war with Negan. Even then,
resources are scarce and Oceanside becomes little
more than a stopping point for people
to travel to more secure locations.
However, the community gets a
lot of credit for being naturally
fortified from the water as well as
standing tall in the face of defeat.
Oceanside also gets top marks for
its resilience and tactical position.
Fortified walls, an endless
supply of fighters, resources,
and a somewhat merit-based economy.
If that sounds like a good time,
The Sanctuary might be up your alley. Of
course, it's not all sunshine and lollipops.
Members of The Sanctuary are
asked to join an incredibly
unforgiving cult that promises safety
in exchange for entering a debt system
similar to that of Grady Memorial Hospital. If
you decide that you're not happy with the deal,
you can always run. However, Negan and The Saviors
are powerful enough to collect on their debts.
Unfortunately, all it takes is a run-in with Rick
Grimes for everything to crumble. The problem with
ruling by fear is that, once you encounter someone
that isn't afraid to take a few hits, you can't
just take your ball and go home. Negan understands
that, which is why he wages total war on Rick and
his alliance of communities. He knows that there
is no way to continue ruling by force if there is
an equally powerful civilization in the area with
a more enlightened view on corporal punishment.
Similar to The Sanctuary, Terminus is a large,
brick facility that is easily fortified and
manned by people to ensure the dead stayed out.
Its people don't even need to risk venturing
out into the world for supplies. Everything they
need in terms of weapons, equipment and, yes,
food, is delivered right to their front door.
After resorting to cannibalism following a
horrific attack, leader Gareth advertises Terminus
as a safe haven for survivors. That's just the
sales pitch, however. Anyone who makes it to
Terminus has to give up their gear before getting
made into a feast for real Terminus residents.
Gareth builds a society that is sustainable and
secure. However, the cost of entry is becoming a
straight up cannibal. One can only survive so
long on morally questionable societal means,
but Gareth manages to make it
last for a surprisingly long time.
This safe haven has literally
everything. Alexandria is a
community that was converted from
an upscale suburban neighborhood
originally designed for sustainability. Once
the apocalypse hits, a professor of architecture
redesigns and fortifies the walls to ensure
that both people and walkers can't get in.
There's enough space and empty houses
for people to really set down some roots,
knowing that they don't have to
worry about the wasteland outside.
Plus, its location near a mall means years
of guaranteed supplies before needing to look
elsewhere. In short, Alexandria ticks off all
the boxes of both safety and comfort. However,
being comfortable and safe isn't always
the best thing for people in an apocalypse.
Similar to the prison, when you have something
that looks this great to a desperate outsider,
it will forever be a target. Since settling
down in Alexandria, its citizens have done
nothing but fight the outside world
to varying degrees of success. Still,
if you like a lot of danger and excitement in
your life, Alexandria might be the place for you.
It may not be the flashiest, it
may not be the most comfortable,
but it's definitely survived and thrived more
than any other community with more potential.
The Hilltop starts out as a historic
museum house in Virginia before
the apocalypse turns it into a safe
zone. When the military abandons it,
the survivors decide it's the
perfect place to build a stronghold.
Its location in the wilderness means that
large invasions by walkers aren't likely
and easy to see coming if the impossible
does occur. Survivors can't really sneak up
on the place and if they did, they'd have large
walls and guards with weapons to contend with.
The community is even self-sustaining, with
fertile ground and dependable crops without
the need to venture outside. However, the true
strength of The Hilltop is in its leadership.
For all his flaws, Gregory was the exact
person Hilltop needed to establish and
secure the safe haven. However, when he
proves ineffective as a wartime leader,
the people are lucky enough
to see Maggie take charge.
When all else is failing around them,
The Hilltop digs in and manage to survive
while other, more seemingly
secure and stocked communities
fall like dominoes. Not only is it a
well-built place to live, but it's led
by people who are just hardened enough to keep
it safe without resorting to drastic measures.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite television shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.